jubilee yeah
you
project pyrotechnic energy plasmoids
like
little fireworks yeah i am you're fired
what it's a pleasure to fire you you
know fireworks goodbye well they're
called plasmoids they're called
fireworks and just because you make them
doesn't make them something else you
realize that i'm trying to put together
a team of superheroes not coordinate the
finale of nine-inch nails at
lollapalooza right well i'm well
i mean maybe if mr sinister is robbing a
bank while tripping on mdma maybe you
could distract him i'm sure you'd be
good at that but i think
maybe if magneto is beating up hippies
at burning man i'll give you a call oh i
know you can fly to ibiza next time
skrillex is spinning for the hippie
flipping rich kids it's a perfect match
he's over here
you're over here wow
if you'd like to make a call
good times
i can't believe you're firing me
actually
could you fire yourself
it would be the first thing you've ever
done for the x-men
you look like the creepiest perverts
real doll special order you look like
hello kitty's best friend goodbye kitty
goodbye kitty
could you look back just for one second
please
yeah you can't hear a finger